[Music]
foreign
it's like three stairs and then my wife
was in the patio and she literally just
remembered this yesterday because she
met somebody that was in the patio with
her and she's like we saw the [__]
rifle the nose of it come out she always
thought she was thinking like she made
that up in her head but the the person
that was standing next to her in the
patio
um they were they had she had fallen and
she was in the corner they were hiding
the [__] muzzle came in and then it
went away
so when Thomas [__] jumped at him the
muzzle went away and they they were like
oh [__] is it coming they all thought
they were gonna die my wife was like
literally she said rich I think that's
when I went into shock because I
literally was praying like oh [__] I'm
gonna die right now like and she was
going through she was going in there I
didn't know where she was at I knew she
was dancing when I last seen her but
everybody flowed out my daughter ended
up in the in the back dressing room I
wiping it up in the patio
because everybody's just trying to get
the [__] out now
the building you go to any bar outside
patio how big is the the fence four
footer right
this club was open 20 years ago in
Colorado Springs they made them put an
eight-foot fence up wow well why
nobody wants to see the gays so there's
an eight foot fence and everybody's in
this [__] patio
and and I couldn't understand it till I
got out the next day and I looked at it
I'm like what the [__] why is there an
eight-foot fence and I asked the owner
and he was like when I put it up that's
what they needed me to do
[__] and I look at my patio I got a
brewery I got I got any they said it was
so that no we could pass beer to the
next guy
I go when the every [__] play and
played too there's a little tiny fence
because you're trying to make it you
know people want to hang out yeah but
nobody's passing [__] beers it was
[__] but that ended up being a
reason people were trapped because
there's an eight foot [__] fence
in the patio so I saw everybody moving
around I saw this dude we went over
there tried to stop him and then we
ended up fighting and uh we go towards
the floor and then apparently he [__]
he pointed at me because he bought a
handgun too right he had his handgun out
and and his rifle I would still believe
was was on the slink around him uh but
Thomas was hanging out to what we were
fighting standing up that's what I think
I don't [__] know I was behind him I
never saw the dude's [__] face but
then and again remember it's [__]
dark music playing loud as [__] lasers
and all the strobes and all that [__]
going off and I'm [__] in this fight
with this dude
and then uh
we get to the ground
and he points the [__] weapon at me
and at that point it was either I
grabbed his hand and I and I laughed
because I told I told Jess they go
there's no [__] way at Jackie Chan
this guy like you know what I'm saying
like I didn't do that [__] there's no
[__] way I'm too stupid to do that
but but it's literally and and having
seen the video it was literally like as
he pointed to me the next scene I'm
[__] swinging on him with it
um so at some point we fought I took the
[__] pistol from him when I grabbed
it it was life
didn't I didn't I know what I know what
a [__] pistol feels like and it's
loaded and I it was light
so I don't know if you dropped the mag I
don't know what the [__] I have no idea
to this day I just know it was light
so I couldn't [__] shoot him so what
do you do this is now my helmet I'm
gonna [__] beat you with it it was
funny because in the video I actually
stopped and I [__] pulled my pants up
because my pants were falling down
because I'm like I'm [__] been
fighting for [__] three minutes right
they weren't I go back down on him and I
pin him to the floor Thomas is at his
head
and and I'm telling Tom this [__]
kick him kick him I'm yelling at people
while I'm just [__] beating on him
with the pistol to back his head [__]
call 9-1-1 call 9-1-1 Thomas keep
[__] kicking him I'm gonna [__]
kill you I'm gonna [__] kill you I'm
motivated so I watched uh Chris
Hemsworth his [__] show on uh the
Discovery Channel I just watched it the
other day he was trying to get hyped up
to go over the little Bridge it was
about stress right how do you handle
stress
the doc was talking about
self-motivation talk like telling
yourself you got to do it I'm like and I
looked at my wife and go that's what the
[__] I was doing I'm like I'm telling
this guy I'm gonna kill him because I
got to keep myself to [__] keep doing
it I'm telling Thomas to keep kicking
him because I need to get him motivated
to do it I'm telling people to call 911
because I still need somebody else to
come [__] do this I can't do this the
rest of my I can't keep doing this and
then as we're fighting Thomas slows down
and I thought he was I knew he was hurt
I just didn't know how and I had told
him move the [__] rifle but the rifle
stayed like almost within Arm's Reach so
that's why I still think it was like on
his his sling and maybe he had pulled it
up but it was still like Thomas is
kicking his head and two is right like
if he would have been able to reach over
to it there's the [__] AR so it's
still sitting right there the whole time
he had grabbed a magazine at one point I
threw the [__] magazine out of his
hand I kept [__] hitting him and then
uh
Thomas was slowing down
and I go I go [__] somebody helped kick
this guy somebody kept and and as that
was happening I think her name's Drea
but this trans woman was walking by and
and I initially and I apologize to her
because I'm like dude I didn't know I
saw glitter [__] high heels going to
this dude's face and I was like maybe it
was a drag performer so I had apologies
to it oh that's good but she's a trans
woman she's just there hanging out
having a good time she was running by
and she heard me say [__] help me
kick this dude help me kick this dude
and in the video she leaves and then she
comes back like oh [__] did this guy
just tell me to help him and then she
goes in and just starts [__] while
Thomas is trying to gain yeah sparkly
high heels [__] dude that's what it was
in his mug shot you see the [__]
heels on his face right yeah so I mean
but I asked somebody to do something
inhuman
that's not easy to live with because I
mean and Dread did it
but damn dude like you don't go through
your life going oh today I'm gonna go
kick some dude right in his [__] face
I'm gonna kick a dude in his head for
six [__] minutes I'm gonna beat a
dude in the back of his head till it
[__] opens up
like I'm in there and I and I and I
[__] keep visually as I'm saying I'm
gonna [__] kill you it was like I'm
I'm the Hannibal scene when he was
[__] slicing away just [__] blood
squirting all over the [__] I thought
I'd [__] he was still finding me man
like [__] he's trying to get up he
was trying to get to his [__] weapons
the whole [__] time dude's a big dude
and I'm a [__] big dude this dude's
big dude
he finally stopped as the cops came in
he stopped moving and I thought it
[__] killed him I thought it [__]
killed him so as soon as the cops came
in I saw the [__] lights and I go yo
it's the [__] I put my hands up I
thought it was a shot I put my [__]
hands up I threw the weapon down and I
said yo this guy get the [__] AR get
the [__] AR I didn't know if he was
gonna still because I was now I was off
of him I wasn't on top of it
so the cops took over him I I in the
video I lean over the [__] I was
smoked with six minutes of [__] hell
smoked
but then I went oh [__] my family so I
went back to where we were seated
and on the floor was Joanne with five
holes in her and chip with two holes in
them
I still hadn't seen my wife and kid
but at the seated table there was only
two people Joanne's laying on the floor
five holes in her
and I looked at her in her eyes and I
went [__] Joanne stay with me stay with
me and I'm talking to her like it was
the [__] it was the worst thing I'd
ever gone through because this is
somebody I truly truly have spent since
07 it's just best friends we watched
them have kids that they didn't have any
kids when we met him they had they have
two babies now you know like and and
they're nine and [__] three or four
their whole family we watched them go
from newlyweds to what they are now
she's a manager at a bank you know
um and he works for the city so I'm like
it's a great couple they're just good
people the one couple that me and my
wife are like oh [__] we can get along
both of us everything's cool right and
and that's hard to find so and so and
we're all into beer and they help us out
of the brewery and [__] just really
close I mean we buy their kids Christmas
presents like they're our kids right
um she's on the floor and he's literally
next to her and he can't [__] a move
because he's shot
what I didn't know and he told me later
is he was trying to put pressure on her
the whole time and when I got to her he
goes rich I can't do it anymore because
he was [__] shot and he can't hold
so he knew she got shot in her her uh
ribs and it went through around her lung
I saw her arm which was I thought she
was going to lose it
um she got shot twice here and twice on
her leg and then shrapnel [__]
everywhere
um but twice in her leg twice in her arm
and once the chest
when I got to her I was like
what the and I'm [__] like Joanne
stay with me and then she's trying to
look at chip
but that's where her arm was and it was
[__] mangled like and I'm like
[__] man so I'm pulling her head away so
she wouldn't see it and go into more
shock she's already in shock I knew that
but if her heart rate goes any higher
it's gonna just [__] bleed out
so then a cop showed up and I'm like put
a [__] tourniquet on her own put a
[__] tourniquet on her arm and I'm
[__] joined stay with me stay with me
I'm [__] moving her head and then
chip was like rich and I and he had his
hand out because they I told this other
guy put a tourniquet on on her leg so
the same and all these cops were
everybody's running around but I had a
cop putting a turn in her arm put a tone
to put one on each of her legs and then
I had to put one on chip
and then I said put another one on her
[__] arm and when he was starting to
do that is when chip was like rich and
because they were about to put his
tourniquet on and he had his hand out
reaching for Joanne and Joanne kept
saying Chip's name and I'm like [__] so
I put her hand in his hand I said Joanne
your hand is in his hand he's got you
I'm looking at her and both me and Chip
had seen her fade Come Back Fade she was
just in and out and we thought we were
gonna lose her so I was like that's my
last moment what the [__] why my he's
reaching for and she can't move her
[__] arm so and then I I said well
maybe if I'll tell her I put your hand
in his hand he is holding your hand
right now then they put the turn again
on him and I never seen a dude in that
much pain because he folded like a
[__] like a chair like just pain
because they tightened that thing down
and it was his whole leg was mingled it
went in and out and just [__] mangled
and when they tighten it down
never seen someone in that much pain
Joanne was in shock he was not in shock
he was taking care of her and then all
of a sudden [__] boom he felt pain
so I was like [__]
and then I'm telling Joanne stay with me
stay with me and then I get [__]
tackled and arrested I'm doing first aid
I'm dealing with cops this whole [__]
time and I get arrested and tackled like
a [__] piece of [__] because I'm
apparently a shooter after I'm helping
save people after I gave you the [__]
[__]
so I nobody's I haven't talked to
anybody about this stuff so there was a
whole thing of that and he dragged me
out of there [__] like a like you
know you're hot no I got dragged out I
got dragged out on you no no no no as
I'm being tackled my face is in the
[__] in the [__] floor I saw my
daughter pop out of the back curtain
just your face she told me later that
she had tried to hug me and the cops
were [__] pushing her off of her
um I don't know about this whole scene
but I saw my wife walk across like a
zombie
she was in so much stock she just like
floated by
then they [__] dragged me out of
there and as I'm getting I'm yelling at
him hey [__] I'm not I'm not the [__]
[__]
people outside think I'm the [__]
shooter because I'm getting dragged out
on my belly with my [__] arms and
legs
uh Shackled up and I'm like and they're
[__] spitting at me [__] cursing
me because they think I'm the [__]
shooter they put me in the car for now
you fighting the cops yeah yeah
absolutely I'm [__] adrenaline is in
and I'm like why the [__] I gave the two
cops that came in the [__] guy I told
three or four cops to put tourniquets
but I also told a lot of cops [__]
move [__] you're walking yeah so
here's where I go back to you've been
shot at before you're managing chaos you
can [__] hey everything's out the
window you need to start helping people
go go go go yeah these guys were like
what the [__] is going on in here
that was the second wave of cops and I'm
like yo [__] wake up run move urgency
let's go get on a [__] body get a
body out of here yeah yeah
yeah couldn't get it through my head
like you know
how and then I'm out there [__]
because I I cussing these [__] out
because I still hadn't seen my I hadn't
held my wife and daughter I didn't know
Joanne was dead I didn't know if Chip
was dead I had no [__] idea I'm in
the back of this car screaming like at
the [__] top of my lungs like what
the [__] going on
so they finally [__] released me uh
about an hour early but then they took
me downtown so I was downtown all night
but I made him take my daughter and my
wife to the hospital because my daughter
[__] broke her knee
trying to escape
um
so I made him drop her off and then I
went to the [__] police station and I
get [__] go through the whole [__]
pictures of everything and blood and all
that [__]
um then I end up in prison pants and
[__] flip-flops because he took all
my [__] so there's it's what's funny is
there's a Marvel my I was wearing jeans
and I had sewed in in covet I learned
how to sew right it's still like [__]
but I learned how to sew right so I had
these patches these marble patches on
these [__] jeans that are in they're
in [__] custody right now where the
[__] they're at covered in blood there's
this [__] every Marvel character with
the [__] little a in the middle and
I'm like yo man I was wearing Avengers
[__] well I [__] did all this crap
dude so it's in custody and my shoes and
all that [__] I'm like [__] that's so
[__] weird you still don't have those
no that's still this I gotta get it I
don't have my clothes man I got my pants
I got my shirt like I'm like that's fine
you know it's it's whatever the [__]
they need to do with it but I just
thought it was [__] hilarious because
I and I'm like
okay so I'm then then they take I'm
gonna take me back to the hospital
they're walking me through the back of
the hospital going and the the community
service folks or whoever they were the
victim Advocate folks they're good folks
the victim advocacy program I don't know
they have it here in California but the
guys in El Paso County amazing those
ladies did [__] for us like I I needed a
wheelchair for cast or like here you go
here's your wheelchair send us the
[__] bills like they were taking care
of everything
um and so I mean really really beautiful
thing you never know it even exists
until you're in this kind of situation
and I was so happy that that did and
just to know that every because chip and
Joanne had their own ad everybody had an
advocate and I was like that's
it's just one of those things you never
knew existed and when they when you find
out about it it's freaking amazing
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign